[Music]
we met it was little Bible Church and he
being a pilot and my dad being a pilot
met and got to know each other and and
then we got to chatting on the phone and
kind of just took off from there became
friends her dad had given me a book when
we first got married David's one of
Dave's first books and in financial
piece and we had read that we had I had
student loan debt pretty considerable
amount of debt for the amount of money I
was making but other than that we didn't
have any credit card debt or car
payments or anything like that but what
caused us to decide to get out of debt
was airlines are pretty fickle so so the
turning point for me it was knowing that
we had too much debt and that I could
possibly lose my job and not be able to
function for even a month I couldn't
fill my car with gas one month because
we had less than a hundred dollars in
the bank that feeling at the pump us
like I will never ever be in this again
my name is will and this is my wife
Kelly and we live in West Alaska and
that worked for as a pilot for Alaska
Airlines and I am a photographer horse
trainer adventure wife with will
[Music]
so when we got married that was one of
the big things he was very strong genius
he was very spontaneous and I was very
much a planner and we clashed a lot and
we look at each other and we go oh my
gosh I'm so thankful though we agree and
and we talked through things when maybe
we have different ideas and then figure
out how to combine those ideas we set
goals every year on our anniversary we'd
talk money goals and we always exceeded
them it was really amazing actually
I hope guys when every dollar came out
that was amazing in the butt but every
dollar at the budget is the most other
than being on board with one another and
having the same goal it's the most
crucial aspect of getting out of debt
yeah you cannot lollygag yeah because
you can save thousands of dollars a year
by budget and knowing what you spend I
don't know we spent this whole last year
deaf free and it was really cool yeah
that was amazing every penny coming in
it didn't have to go out unless we
wanted it to that was a really crazy
feeling there is there's a turning point
at which we were just like oh I hate
debt but then there was also a second
turning point of going from we hate the
mindset of high
we hate debt too we want to be really
good stewards of our money and and that
that was another shift let's not just
stop here at the student loans
let's tackle the house now too as I got
raises we never changed our lifestyle we
would put every single Ray's into the
house
as the numbers started going down we
passed the to two hundred thousand mark
and that was really cool to watch that
never go to one and as big deal and when
we passed the hundred thousand it was
like we were on a roll
it was just what we were militant I
think it was just more of a slog yeah I
mean yeah you're at the base of a big
mountain we had a trip planned down to
the Kenai Peninsula is about a four-hour
drive out of Anchorage and we realized
that trip coincided with the month that
we were gonna pay the house off we're
known as kind of like the crazy
adventure couple we go and do things
that most people would not do calm
poetic that were doing an adventure and
in the ping off our house in the process
of it it took us eight and a half years
to pay off my student loans in the house
it was it was long in fact we've talked
about her recently I don't think we
realized what kind of a sacrifice was
until after we were done it became the
normal yeah I became normal we started
with a nearly quarter million dollars of
negative net worth and we could call in
and do the millionaire our thing
[Music]
next year and that's not that's not at
all the brag
that's simply a the way the plan is set
up it works you know when you own your
house or you can take two pads you make
more money or you can spend time with
your family and that's the that's the
branch that I would like to take is is
more quality time being able to dream
bigger than we ever thought possible I
mean when you start talking millions of
dollars and what you could do with that
the way it would affect your life it's
pretty incredible yeah with all the
young couples out there if you start
starting now you would be blown out of
the water what you can do and make goals
dream big
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]